hey guys what's up it's andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video guys
i'm here to show you some very cool
things on gme we have a good situation
we have some stop hunting and we have a
bullish engulfing so let's analyze all
of that and let's see what can happen
next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so the very first thing i
want to tell you guys just like i did
yesterday in my amc video is that
trading sensors.com is finally ready
guys the link is in the description of
this video go there watch it guys tell
me what you think i wrote an article as
well myself sorry for the little
mistakes if there are some i think it's
interesting and this is the place it
took me like six months one year to
create this place i created a course
guys i'm talking about that for some
time the course is available as well
guys so go take it you have one week of
50 discount then the price is going to
increase the price might be expensive
you're going to tell me but trust me
it's a good investment on yourself and
you're fully refunded if you don't like
it but i'm sure guys you gonna love it
because this content you can't find it
anywhere it's based on my professional
experience you're gonna see guys you
you're really gonna learn a lot a lot a
lot it's gonna help you to improve your
results so this is the best advice i can
give you guys right now go take this
course and you're gonna love it so right
now i want to show you a little bit
what's going to be in this course
because we have a good example so gme
guys all right so i know i'm doing
technical analysis on some manipulated
stocks so it's not easy but it's still
giving me good results guys it's giving
me good levels that are identified using
consolidations guys you need to focus on
consolidations because this is where you
have liquidity this is where you have
those uh areas that once they crossed
they usually give the direction and here
we have a lot of interesting things that
happen so first
this trend line guys i'm not gonna go
through this breakout again we have a
breakout here that was not perfect but
better than amc one because the
consolidation was better so we can use
fibs to enter here we went to the 61.8
percent fib ratio all right guys so i'm
explaining that in my course as well why
61.8 in this situation 150 why 28.2 go
there watch it you're gonna see so here
uh bam bam bam we have a lot of
interesting things okay so i i really
want to share everything with you so
here we have a breakout that is okay
quality like i said because the
consideration is good the volume
increase is not impressive but good
enough then we consolidate in this range
okay and i was telling you guys
last week that this consolidation looks
really great how do you know if your
consideration is great you check
bollinger bands bam
and bollinger bands we're getting
tighter but they're not super tight yet
okay but they're getting tighter okay
here they're tight they're not that
tight actually but this consideration is
nice
and we just as the bollinger bands are
completed using 20 days we need a few
more days it's been like 10 12 days
we're considerating here so in a few
days they're gonna become tight and the
situation is going to be good for a nice
breakout but what happened here guys
look you're going to learn something
very cool what happened here guys is
some stop hunting situation so i have a
double information that i want to show
you first let me share the stop hunting
situations what is the stop hunt so we
were consolidating here all right the
price action on low volume guys this is
very important the low volume tells you
that something is gonna happen soon and
what happened guys we had this war
russia ukraine so the price dropped
heavily so we had a breakout okay so
usually when you have a breakout first
you need to wait for the candle to close
below so here the breakout signal was
not given let's be very clear there was
a stop hunting phenomenon that happened
here so what is that it's a trading
strategy based on breakouts that are not
strong a breakout that is not good
enough instead of selling it in this
situation as the breakout would be on
the downside you buy it you do the
opposite of breakout trading you go
against breakout traders but here once
again the breakout didn't occur
and you do that when the breakout
situation is weak here i won't go too
much into detail because i want to show
you more things but this was a weak
situation and those and i'm explaining
that very well in my course by the way
yes those top hunters they bought here
the market and brought it back inside
the consolidation range so look guys
right now the situation we're in
we went down so bears got trapped guys
this is a bear trap and when bears get
trapped guys they usually become bulls
just think about what happens to you for
example when you buy on the breakout and
it goes against you do you still want to
buy lower usually you know you should
buy lower but you are losing money so
you're afraid so you don't buy and
before that
if the breakout was not happening if you
didn't buy the breakout and the price
just goes lower in the consideration
then you would have bought so you would
have been a buyer before the breakout
but after the fake out it goes higher
then comes back you're not a buyer
anymore so basically you were bull and
you transformed not into a bear being
into neutral investors so here's the
same thing is happening so the bears
that were here that lost money they're
not going to put pressure anymore here
um they will but less so right now here
we had balance before the balance is
broken now and both are in control
inside that range so for now we don't
have the breakout but if we do break out
here guys
this situation would be perfect and let
me show you something guys look at that
now look at that this is my course guys
so i can show you a quick overview
you have 30 slides i'm not going to show
you everything but guys i did everything
myself that's why it took me so long but
trust me guys you're going to love it
and here look at the situation so i did
that guys maybe two months ago i drew
that guy's candle by candle all right so
it's a lot of work but it's not what
took me the most time in my course don't
worry and look at this situation i'm
showing you how to improve the breakout
quality okay so i'm not going to go
through everything but you can see that
here guys this is in the list all right
whenever you have this guys okay stop
hunting a small fake out in the opposite
direction just before the breakout so
here we have the consolidation okay
consolidation consolidation here we have
a resistance
and here we have a fake out guys okay a
fake out in the opposite direction so on
the downside
just before the breakout then when
you're coming back in the consolidation
area the as i told you guys the players
changed right bears are not as bearish
as they used to be they are scared a
little bit they lost money so they are
not going to take the same trades they
used to trade they used to take before
so the balance that was here inside this
consolidation because the consolidation
is a period of balance is broken so it's
it doesn't mean we're gonna break out
but if we do break out it's looking very
well so i'm not sure we're gonna close
above 130 all right i can't be sure if
anything but if we do guys this
situation would be looking very good and
we'll probably go quickly to 160. okay
so this is about the step hunt the
second information guys and it's the
same for amc
we have a bullish and golfing guys oh
right what is the bullish engulfing is
when one candle fully engulfs the one
before this big candle is eating the
small red candle before it's a reversal
pattern that is giving good results when
found at the end of a downtrend here we
have four red candles so just like i
dino names yesterday guys look
you can just tap here engulfing and you
select the bullish one i'm on trading
view i click on indicators and you're
gonna see all the bullish engulfing on
gme that happened in the past so just
like i did on amc i want to check i
didn't check before guys so let's
analyze together what happened here we
had one
it was followed by a range market then a
move down so this was definitely not a
good signal it happened after two green
candles so this bullish engulfing would
have not been valid anyways then this
one it happens after one green candle
but in the strong downtrend it was
followed by strong move up rejected and
then we went range okay so not a good
signal are there some other ones and
then we had some two here in the past a
very long time ago and here guys some
bullish engine things so this one was
very nice it would got followed by a
massive move up and this one no okay
guys so let's be
honest let's you know face the truth
buddhish and girl things didn't give
good results on gme in the past year
it's still a reversal pattern it's a
reversal cannot see pattern we still
have to stop hunting so to me it's still
a bullish situation but once again as
long as we are below 130 i mean we are
not that bullish all right we are
neutral i would say
uh we don't want to see a close below
115 guys this wouldn't be looking so
good we still have the bullish momentum
coming from this breakout that once
again is quite good quality and as you
saw guys it it was bought at the 61.8
retracement so it's a bullish situation
so to conclude guys because as you know
i like to give you my view the situation
is bullish bulls and control uh to me on
the medium term also in the short term i
would say i would say both are in
control on the short term medium term
bears are still in control in the long
term guys we are below the 200 day
moving average here and we are below the
160 level i mean booze and control on
the short immediate term we're probably
going to come to 160 sooner or later
guys get rejected then question probably
consolidate and hopefully you guys break
out here maybe in april or may i give
roughly the same uh levels and time
period for amc guys so i hope you
enjoyed this video i hope i managed to
explain to you some cool and new things
and guys don't forget to click on the
link to see my website to subscribe to
the course and you're gonna learn a lot
a lot of things guys and i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget as well to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys